how are your parents with your fame how
are they they must be very proud of you
yeah they for sure are which is
the sweetest thing in the world um
but uh but my mom so i mean right when i
got the job
and this was probably i remember like
two weeks into it
my mom and i were in a public restroom
and there were there were a lot of
people in there and i i was like mom i'm
gonna wait for you
in the lobby and she goes okay
heidi gardner my
daughter and
i exited and of course this was two
weeks in nasa now i mean it takes
probably three years for anyone to know
who you are that's nice but
for sure no one knew who i was so i
i go out and i sit in the lobby and my
mom comes out and i was like hey mom
will you sit with me for a second she
was like yeah honey
and i go hey i i saw what you did
in the bathroom and um you know i'm just
not
very comfortable with that i don't i
don't like that and she goes
honey i'm just bragging that's so funny
my uh
my mom when i had the late night show
first couple years into having the
late-night show she used to really do
this
she got a bunch of late night with conan
o'brien key chains and she kept them in
her purse
and she should we would go through she
would go through the line
uh at the local supermarket in brookline
massachusetts
and then the person would be bagging her
groceries and she'd say
do you like television and the guy'd be
like uh
yeah sure do you ever watch late night
television
and you'd say um yeah i watched some
late night do you ever see conan o'brien
and the guy be like
yeah i know i i see that show do you
like conan brian
he's okay well guess what he's my son
and you can have a keychain
i could just picture all these people
reluctantly taking
a keychain but it makes them so happy
and that makes me happy to hear because
i think i'm always thinking like oh my
god people must be
so annoyed by my mom but if i was that
cashier i would think that was the
cutest thing in the world i would take
it
yeah like does your dad brag about you
yes so my dad
he's he tries to do it a little more
low-key he drives for uber
and he likes to um do like the early
pickup so like airport runs or
but a lot of times he does sunday
morning like
picking people up from the bars or
wherever they've been and so he'll tell
stories
of like picking up a whole like
bachelorette girls from a bachelorette
party
and like they'll you know be out on an
all-nighter
and like trying to settle in and my
dad's like so
ladies at 4 30 in the morning did you
guys watch
snl last night we're like
no we were at a rave we were clubbing
yeah um sometimes he's like
but some of them but then i say but have
you ever watched and then you know and
then they know who
you are and they really like your work
well that's nice
yeah that's nice i'm glad i'm glad that
you're i think it's a very nice thing
i'm sure they're
extraordinarily proud of you and uh
you are crazy talented you're crazy
talented and i'm very happy for you
i really am it's nice i get uh
i don't know what it is but when when i
see young people
uh that are inordinately talented doing
good work it just makes me happy i just
like restores my faith in the whole
system you know well you know for years
i
um had your quote uh if you're kind and
you work hard
amazing things will happen right over my
bed so oh that's so sweet
that's nice well guess what what i
should do is amend that quote
and say amazing things will happen and
then you'll get your [ __ ] stolen out of
a theater
i'll just add that at the end